- Congratulations on completing
Khan for Educators initial course.
Your efforts to grow your
professional learning
inspire all of us at Khan Academy.
While this course has come to an end,
Khan Academy offers other
communication channels
and opportunities to keep learning.
From the Teacher dashboard,
click on the Resources tab.
Here you will find additional materials
that may help you use Khan
Academy with your students.
Also, check out the Help Center
where you can find a series of articles
including frequently asked questions
and guides for students,
teachers and parents.
In addition, from the Help Center,
you can report a technical problem
and receive assistance
from our support team.
To learn more about Khan
Academy's training initiatives
or other projects, keep
an eye on your inbox.
We'll always make an effort
to keep our educators in the know.
You can also follow our
teacher-exclusive Facebook group,
and Teach With Khan Twitter account.
For additional teacher-focused videos,
like interviews with
our teacher ambassadors
or past webinars,
visit our Khan Academy
Teacher YouTube channel.
Or for more on remote
teaching and learning,
check out our Keep everyone learning site
for resources for students,
teachers and families,
available in English and Spanish.
Finally, if you'd be willing
to share a few moments of your time,
we'd love to get your
feedback on this course
and how we can best support
teachers everywhere.
If you'd be willing to provide feedback,
please use the survey
found in this lesson.
If you have any difficulties
accessing the survey,
please contact
teachereducation@khanacademy.org.
Once again, congratulations on completing
Khan for Educators initial course.
We look forward to hearing more about
the incredible things you
are doing with your students.